so the third and final insight that i've
taken from this year's conversations has
been that for me the most successful
recruitment consultants and businesses
are in the game of selling solutions not
people
what i mean by that is that the best
recruiters are not transactional
recruiters they really listen to their
clients needs and what they're then
going to do is come up with solutions to
solve those problems solution selling it
isn't something that you typically hear
in the recruitment industry you
typically hear putting bums on seats and
i think that's really changed this year
one of the key things that i've noticed
is that there's been this real rise in
talent partner models embedded
recruiters on sites with their partners
and really ingraining themselves with
their clients culture
to influence their hiring approach to
influence the recruitment process and so
much more so i think what we're going to
see a lot more of next year is
recruiters being solution
focused and selling genuine solutions
and that's been the third final insight
from this year
[Music]